Lucia: 那个我刚才也没找到
Lucia: I couldn't find it earlier either.
Lucia: 你说裱花袋也在这
Lucia: You said the piping bags are here.
Lucia: 我看到了
Lucia: I see them.
Lucia: 但是裱花嘴我也没看到
Lucia: But I didn't see the piping tips.
Lucia: 今天应该把它拿出来
Lucia: We should have taken them out today.
Tasha: 他洗的对
Tasha: He washed them, right?
Jake: 我洗的
Jake: I washed them.
Lucia: 嗯哈哈你回忆一下
Lucia: Hmm, haha, try to recall.
Lucia: 回忆回忆
Lucia: Remember, remember.
Jake: 难道在这个地方
Jake: Could it be in this place?
Jake: 这些地方
Jake: Or these places?
Jake: 不能啊
Jake: It can't be.
Jake: 不能够
Jake: No way.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 这里面也没有
Lucia: It's not in here either.
Lucia: 这应该是
Lucia: This should be...
Lucia: 就是就是普通的磨具
Lucia: Just regular molds.
Tasha: 差不多吧
Tasha: More or less.
Jake: 没有一点线索呢
Jake: Not a single clue, huh?
Jake: 我应该不会扔了吧
Jake: I shouldn't have thrown it away, right?
Lucia: 哎找到了
Lucia: Oh, found it!
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 嗯？
Lucia: Hmm?
Tasha: 那是转换器
Tasha: That's a converter.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Jake:裱花嘴
Jake: The piping tips.
Lucia: 啊你的也是这样子的
Lucia: Ah, yours are like this too.
Jake:是什么
Jake: What is it?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你的还有一会
Jake: Yours still has a little while.
Jake:你的得有个十分钟吧
Jake: Yours will take about ten minutes.
Lucia: 我站这边
Lucia: I'll stand over here.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jake:差不多了
Jake: Almost there.
Lucia: 这给他穿过去啊
Lucia: Pass this through to him.
Lucia: 好香啊
Lucia: Smells so good.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 这个没有主要就是主要就是
Lucia: This one doesn't have, mainly, mainly...
Tasha: 我这上面还是一个
Tasha: I still have one here.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Hold on a second.
Lucia: 我把这个擦一下
Lucia: Let me wipe this off.
Tasha: 哦对他这上面还是有油要把他
Tasha: Oh right, there's still some oil on it, we need to...
Lucia: 弄下来
Lucia: Get it off.
Tasha: 转下来
Tasha: Turn it off.
Lucia: OK我是不是一会得把裤子洗下去
Lucia: OK, should I go wash my pants later?
Katrina: 哦不是说有洗衣机吗
Katrina: Oh, didn't you say there's a washing machine?
Jake:对在这
Jake: Yes, it's here.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 我可能也要洗
Katrina: I might need to wash too.
Katrina: 哎呀但我要是洗的话
Katrina: Oh no, but if I wash...
Katrina: 我明天我要不穿牛仔裤或者之类的啊
Katrina: Tomorrow, should I not wear jeans or something?
Lucia: 别地方应该没有
Lucia: There shouldn't be any other places.
Jake:牛仔裤跳舞
Jake: Dancing in jeans?
Lucia: 好问题如果跳什么舞还得思考半天
Lucia: Good question. If we need to dance, we have to think about it for a while.
Katrina: 对如果要跳舞的话
Katrina: Yes, if we have to dance...
Katrina: 我有没有带合适的衣服
Katrina: Do I have the right clothes?
Lucia: 不跳那种幅度大的话就穿裙子也可以
Lucia: If it's not a big move dance, wearing a skirt should be fine.
Lucia: 就你今天那个裙子
Lucia: Like the skirt you wore today.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Katrina: 嗯我还有个裙子
Katrina: Hmm, I have another skirt.
Katrina: 我带了两条裙子
Katrina: I brought two skirts.
Lucia: 一会一会我们再商量商量
Lucia: We can discuss more later.
Katrina: 挑个短短的
Katrina: Pick a shorter one.
Katrina: 好杨老板就慢慢统一服装
Katrina: Okay, Jake will slowly unify the clothing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我觉得可以有哈哈哈哈
Lucia: I think it's possible, hahaha.
Jake:什么什么样了
Jake: What, what kind of clothing?
Jake:什么样的服装
Jake: What kind of outfit?
Katrina: 先要确定我们跳什么类型的舞吧
Katrina: First we need to decide what type of dance we're doing.
Lucia: 取决于我们要跳什么舞
Lucia: Depends on what dance we're doing.
Katrina: 就
Katrina: Just...
Katrina: 好多东西都要现
Katrina: A lot of things need to...
Alice:你穿什么我就穿什么
Alice: I'll wear whatever you wear.
Katrina: 好多东西都要现买哦
Katrina: A lot of things need to be bought on the spot.
Katrina: 好直接逛街去
Katrina: Alright, let's just go shopping.
Jake:逛街去可以
Jake: Going shopping is fine.
Katrina: 逛街
Katrina: Shopping.
Katrina: 戴着眼镜逛街
Katrina: Wearing glasses while shopping.
Alice:让采集一下中国人位
Alice: Let’s gather some data about Chinese people.
Lucia: 要不戴着眼镜逛淘宝吧也算是一种书
Lucia: How about shopping on Taobao with glasses on? That’s also a kind of reading.
Katrina: 正在逛淘
Katrina: I’m currently browsing Taobao.
Jake:呃可以啊
Jake: Uh, sure.
Lucia: 哎你的眼镜好了
Lucia: Hey, your glasses are ready.
Jake:可以呀
Jake: Sure thing.
Katrina: 嗯我在看我房间装饰
Katrina: Hmm, I’m looking at decorations for my room.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 买一个好难
Katrina: It’s so hard to buy one.
Lucia: 这好难哦
Jake:突然有了某些微醺
Jake: Suddenly feeling a bit tipsy.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 装饰房间
Lucia: Decorating the room.
Katrina: 突然想到我小红书收藏了很久的风铃
Katrina: Suddenly remembered the wind chime I saved on Xiaohongshu for a long time.
Lucia: 嘿嘿
Lucia: Hehe.
Jake:你让大家陪你一起凑单
Jake: You want everyone to help you with a group purchase?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 那我如果买热胶枪的话能报销吗
Lucia: If I buy a hot glue gun, can it be reimbursed?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia: 因为假如这口不是
Lucia: Because if this isn’t...
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: ...isn’t, isn’t.
Lucia: 他不是很贵
Lucia: It’s not very expensive.
Jake:ok
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 他是一个手工很常见的东西
Lucia: It’s a common crafting tool.
Jake:行啊可以啊
Jake: Sure, that’s fine.
Lucia: 就假如说我们要做水母灯的话
Lucia: Like if we’re making jellyfish lamps.
Katrina: 热熔胶那个
Katrina: The hot glue gun, right?
Lucia: 可能会用哦
Lucia: We might use it.
Katrina: 就是那个枪那个胶是吧
Katrina: The gun and the glue, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 那不是
Katrina: Isn’t that...
Katrina: 20块钱吗
Katrina: ...20 yuan?
Lucia: 对对那个很便宜
Lucia: Yeah, that’s very cheap.
Lucia: 其实我家里有一个但是好久没用了
Lucia: Actually, I have one at home but haven’t used it in a long time.
Lucia: 然后我没带过来
Lucia: And I didn’t bring it.
Lucia: 因为我不是很确定
Lucia: Because I wasn’t sure.
Lucia: 我们具具体会不会用到它
Lucia: If we’d actually need it.
Katrina: 20块钱就能买好多
Katrina: You can buy a lot for just 20 yuan.
Alice:你下面剪一个小孔要不然你那空气排不下去你就挤不下去
Alice: You need to cut a small hole below, otherwise the air can't escape and you can't squeeze it out.
Jake:对20块钱确实用不着批准
Jake: Yeah, 20 bucks definitely doesn't need approval.
Alice:不用哪个嘴直接就挤下去了
Alice: No need for the nozzle, just squeeze it directly.
Tasha: 他们那种老黄
Tasha: They have that kind of old yellow one.
Alice:啊那就是这样子无所谓
Alice: Ah, it's like that, doesn't matter.
Alice:一根小小的头发
Alice: A tiny little hair.
Tasha: 但他是捡快递的走
Tasha: But he's the one who picks up the packages.
Alice:嗯他擦过没啊
Alice: Hmm, did he wipe it?
Lucia: 那你用刀在这里划一下就是
Lucia: Then you use a knife to cut here.
Lucia: 嗯小心手
Lucia: Hmm, be careful with your hand.
Lucia: 嗯要大概要多长时间
Lucia: Hmm, how long will it take approximately?
Alice:小一点的
Alice: Just a little.
Jake:一半
Jake: Half.
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thanks.
Lucia: 嗯再往外再往上一点这样可以吗
Lucia: Hmm, a bit more outward and upward, is this okay?
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice:嗯好好就这样就这样开
Alice: Hmm, alright, just like that, open it.
Lucia: 看一下
Lucia: Take a look.
Tasha: 开
Tasha: Open it.
Jake:开开什么开
Jake: Open what?
Lucia: 你试一下就可能要用手
Lucia: Try it, you might need to use your hands.
Lucia: 再蹬一蹬
Lucia: Push again.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 我拧不开必须要剪刀
Tasha: I can't unscrew it, need scissors.
Lucia: 嗯那怎么办呢嗯
Lucia: Hmm, what to do then, hmm.
Lucia: 那个剪刀够干净吗
Lucia: Are the scissors clean enough?
Jake:不不太够吧
Jake: Not really, I guess.
Tasha: 哎我还是个天才
Tasha: Hey, I'm still a genius.
Lucia: 直接展示
Lucia: Show it directly.
Jake:你你怎么操作的啊
Jake: How did you do it?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake:你你怎么做的
Jake: How did you do it?
Lucia: 我要录一下啊
Lucia: I want to record it.
Tasha: 啊不有没有
Tasha: Ah, no, wait.
Tasha: 人要来挤
Tasha: Someone needs to squeeze.
Lucia: 我们先学习一下
Lucia: Let's learn first.
Tasha: 没有什么学习的
Tasha: Nothing to learn here.
Jake:这我得学习吗这
Jake: Do I need to learn this?
Lucia: 这得学得学习
Lucia: Yes, need to learn.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:这水平很高啊
Jake: Your skills are top-notch!
Lucia: 好有意思
Lucia: This is so interesting.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my!
Alice:可以给我挤一个就一个点的吗因为我不吃奶油
Alice: Can you just give me a tiny bit because I don't eat cream?
Katrina: 给
Katrina: Here you go.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:杨老板
Alice: Jake.
Jake:来起一个
Jake: Let's raise a glass.
Katrina: 亲自操刀
Katrina: Doing it myself.
Alice:时间
Alice: Time.
Jake:哈哈哈多少有点奇怪
Jake: Hahaha, it's kind of weird.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事草莓往上一压就看不出来了
Lucia: It's fine, just press the strawberry on top, and you won't notice.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 我来
Katrina: I got this.
Jake:你来
Jake: You got this.
Jake:最后让眼镜给个评分
Jake: Let's have the glasses give a score at the end.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈他有这功能吗
Lucia: Hahaha, can they do that?
Jake:可以让他有
Jake: We can make them.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:真好玩
Jake: This is so fun.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 为什么我不能在想断的地方把它断掉
Lucia: Why can't I break it at the point I want?
Katrina: 因为断不了
Katrina: Because it won't break.
Jake:挺好挺好这样挺好
Jake: It's fine, this is fine.
Lucia: 下去你给我下去
Lucia: Get down, get down.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 但是他坠在这里
Lucia: But it's hanging here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要再来一个吗
Lucia: Should we do another one?
Jake:没墨了
Jake: Out of ink.
Alice:没让我弄个平
Alice: Didn't you want it flat?
Jake:哦平一点
Jake: Oh, flatter.
Lucia: 哇这个好平
Lucia: Wow, this is really flat.
Jake:可以很平
Jake: It can be very flat.
Jake:对
Jake: Yep.
Lucia: 那我再来挤一个好了
Lucia: Let me squeeze another one then.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: 挤的各有特色
Tasha: Each one's squeezing style is unique
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哦我还以为你就这样断了
Tasha: Oh, I thought you were just going to stop there
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 没有本来想给他画个什么花
Lucia: No, I actually wanted to draw a flower for him
Lucia: 结果发现画了一个圈之后
Lucia: But after drawing a circle
Lucia: 也画不出什么了
Lucia: I couldn't draw anything else
Lucia: 这好奇怪啊
Lucia: This is so weird
Lucia: 像拔青一样
Lucia: It's like pulling weeds
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Lucia: 哈哈等一下
Lucia: Haha, wait a moment
Alice:这是食症
Alice: This is a food symptom
Jake:这是花
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Alice:祛湿症哈哈哈
Alice: Moisture removal symptom, hahaha
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Jake:这草
Jake: This grass
Lucia: 行再来一个
Lucia: Okay, another one
Alice:可以画个笑脸
Alice: You can draw a smiley face
Tasha: 我觉得有点多
Tasha: I think it's a bit too much
Tasha: 大家可以多挤一点
Tasha: Everyone can squeeze a bit more
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 最后一个
Tasha: The last one
Jake:呵压力很大
Jake: Haha, so much pressure
Tasha: 让杨老板挤一个大开场
Tasha: Let Jake do a big opening squeeze
Jake:压力很大
Jake: So much pressure
Lucia: 对对对来个大的哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, do a big one, hahaha
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 嚯 怎么还剩这么大一包
Tasha: Wow, how is there still such a big pack left?
Tasha: 那这个是不是不要了
Tasha: So this one, should we not use it?
Tasha: 草莓
Tasha: Strawberry
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one
Alice:可以吃了吗
Alice: Can we eat it now?
Lucia: 草莓放冰冰上吃
Lucia: Eat the strawberry on top of the ice
Tasha: 吃
Tasha: Eat
Jake:压力到我这边
Jake: The pressure is on me.
Tasha: 全部挤掉
Tasha: Squeeze it all out.
Lucia: 挤满吧
Lucia: Fill it up.
Tasha: 这就是你了
Tasha: That's all you.
Jake:挤满到我这边挤来
Jake: Fill it up and squeeze it over here.
Jake:哎这还行啊
Jake: Hey, this is okay.
Lucia: 哎这还怪好看的
Lucia: Hey, this actually looks good.
Lucia: 哎果然没有压力就是不一样
Lucia: See, it's different without the pressure.
Jake:哦豁哈哈哈
Jake: Oh ho ho, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 你倒的奶油太多
Tasha: You poured too much cream.
Katrina: 这颜色好看
Katrina: This color looks nice.
Tasha: 还有那么多怎么办
Tasha: What do we do with the rest?
Lucia: 给哪个少的再加一点
Lucia: Add a bit more to those with less.
Lucia: 如果哪位同学会吃掉他
Lucia: If anyone can eat it.
Jake:哎这样挺好
Jake: Hey, this is good.
Lucia: 可以吃的话
Lucia: If it can be eaten.
Lucia: 啊好看耶
Lucia: Ah, it looks nice.
Jake:水平还是高
Jake: The skill is still high.
Tasha: 专业
Tasha: Professional.
Jake:巨石阵批发
Jake: Stonehenge wholesale.
Lucia: 巨石阵批发
Lucia: Stonehenge wholesale.
Jake:哎哎这个3个变成了10个
Jake: Hey, these three became ten.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
老板：哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 完了完了
Tasha: It's over, it's over.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
Katrina: 喷出来了
Katrina: It spilled.
Katrina: 主打一个不浪费
Katrina: No waste is the key.
Alice:直接往里吸溜吧
Alice: Just slurp it directly.
Jake:唔
Jake: Mmm.
Lucia: 好好草莓
Lucia: Nice strawberries.
Katrina: 草莓奶油苹果
Katrina: Strawberry cream apple.
Lucia: 奶油苹果
Lucia: Cream apple.
Alice:好我要这个
Alice: Okay, I want this one.
Jake:拍一张
Jake: Take a picture.
Alice:杨老板您的易路
Alice: Jake, your turn.
Katrina: 对拍一张
Katrina: Yeah, take a picture.
Tasha: 艺术草莓
Tasha: Artistic strawberry.
Jake:哈哈我的艺术草莓
Jake: Haha, my artistic strawberry.
Jake:我的我的
Jake:挺好的我很开心哈哈哈
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: 怎么办最后不浪费剪得好丑啊
Jake:不丑啊这个各有特色
Lucia: 对不丑不丑各有物色
Jake:真的是你远远看的
Jake:真不知道是什么哈哈哈
Alice:我来接一个吧
Lucia: 我先把我点的这个跟巨石阵一样
Lucia: 给吃了吧
Katrina: 再不要这个
Lucia: 嗯
Jake:谢谢谢谢您
Katrina: 再把我这个
Jake:这该怎么下口呢
Alice:先舔一下
Alice:扭一扭扭一扭
Jake:泡一泡
Alice:先需要勺子
Jake:结果没有
Jake: So, no result?
Jake:那就硬吃是吧
Jake: Guess we'll just eat it as is.
Lucia: 嗯好好吃
Lucia: Mmm, it's really tasty.
Lucia: 这个奶油调的也好好
Lucia: The cream is really well-made too.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:第一视角是是是巨石阵
Jake: The first-person view is like Stonehenge.
Jake:吃蛋糕
Jake: Eating cake.
Lucia: 哼
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:眼线先吃
Jake: Eyeliner first.
Jake:就就是这样
Jake: Just like that.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好敬业哈哈哈
Lucia: So professional, hahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehehe.
Lucia: 我应该怎样才能把它撕开
Lucia: How should I tear this open?
Lucia: 哎呦吓我一跳
Lucia: Whoa, that scared me.
Jake:哎小心一点
Jake: Hey, be careful.
Alice:哎楼下这个厕所门是坏的
Alice: Hey, the bathroom door downstairs is broken.
Alice:还是上面的坏的
Alice: Or is it the one upstairs?
Lucia: 好像俩都是坏的
Lucia: I think both are broken.
Lucia: 是好的呀
Lucia: No, they're fine.
Jake:就就那个是好的
Jake: That one is good.
Alice:就锁不了
Alice: It can't be locked.
Jake:就那个是好的应该
Jake: That one should be good.
Alice:那洗澡的话
Alice: What about taking a shower?
Katrina: 楼上的楼上的这个是好的
Katrina: The one upstairs is good.
Lucia: 哦不这个是坏的
Lucia: Oh no, this one is broken.
Katrina: 我可以锁上
Katrina: I can lock it.
Lucia: 啊这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Katrina: 嗯就把他那个一拨一下就好
Katrina: Yeah, just give it a quick turn.
Lucia: 你说的是这边这个还是那边那个
Lucia: Are you talking about this side or that side?
Katrina: 我你房间那个啊
Katrina: The one in your room.
Alice:这个是好的吗
Alice: Is this one good?
Lucia: 那个是好的那个好像
Lucia: That one seems good.
Lucia: 反正我没锁上
Lucia: Anyway, I couldn't lock it.
Lucia: 也可能是我操作有误
Lucia: Maybe I did it wrong.
Katrina: 他不是往左还是往右
Katrina: Isn't it left or right?
Jake:哎呀  完了
Jake: Oh no, it's done.
Katrina: 拨一下就可以锁上
Katrina: Just turn it and it will lock.
Alice:捡一捡把它吃了吧
Alice: Pick it up and eat it.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:算了
Alice: Never mind.
Katrina: 3秒钟过了
Katrina: 3 seconds are up.
Jake:完了
Jake: It's over.
Alice:你可以从外面打开一下吗
Alice: Can you try opening it from the outside?
Alice:我看能锁上没
Alice: Let me see if it locks.
Jake:这个应该不行
Jake: It probably won't work.
Jake:我理解算了吧
Jake: I think we should just leave it.
Alice:嗯锁不了
Alice: Yeah, it won't lock.
Alice:坏一点
Alice: It's a bit broken.
Katrina: 你看我眼睛上的彩虹
Katrina: Look at the rainbow in my eyes.
Tasha: 好的就是花少泥
Tasha: The good one has less mud.
Lucia: 哈哈不是你烤的吗
Lucia: Haha, didn't you bake it?
Lucia: 大家一起烤的呵呵
Lucia: We all baked it together, hehe.
Lucia: 关键还是有你的指导和经验烤的
Lucia: The key was your guidance and experience.
Tasha: 好心人
Tasha: Kind-hearted person.
Lucia: 鼓掌哈哈哈
Lucia: Applause, hahaha.
Jake:鼓掌
Jake: Applause.
Tasha: 明天可以做进阶版的
Tasha: We can make an advanced version tomorrow.
Tasha: 就是他吃了之后会爆浆里面哦
Tasha: After eating it, it'll burst with filling.
Lucia: 哦这么酷哈哈哈我以为
Lucia: Oh, that's so cool, hahaha, I thought...
Lucia: 我一直以为
Lucia: I always thought
Lucia: 这种东西
Lucia: This kind of thing
Lucia: 就是只有蛋糕店才可以做出来
Lucia: Could only be made in a bakery
Lucia: 就是单靠个人的力量是做不出来的
Lucia: Like, you can't make it by yourself
Lucia: 哈哈只有一种神秘力量才能做出来
Lucia: Haha, only some mysterious power could make it
Lucia: 我们的神秘力量
Lucia: Our mysterious power
Jake:每天
Jake: Every day
Alice:我吃过两个
Alice: I've eaten two
Katrina: 等一会等一会吃嘛
Katrina: Wait a minute, wait to eat
Katrina: 我等一会就会消化
Katrina: I'll digest in a bit
Alice:谁没吃过两个
Alice: Who hasn't eaten two?
Katrina: 我还没吃过两个
Katrina: I haven't eaten two yet
Lucia: 我还没吃过两个
Lucia: I haven't eaten two yet
Tasha: 他还没吃啊
Tasha: He hasn't eaten yet
Jake:啊我怎么没吃
Jake: Ah, how come I haven't eaten?
Jake:我刚吃完就没吃
Jake: I just finished and didn't eat
Jake:哪个是我的
Jake: Which one is mine?
小薇;这个
Tasha: This one
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey
Katrina: 谁看见我线了
Katrina: Did anyone see my cable?
Jake:休息一下
Jake: Take a break
Katrina: 就剩一个头了
Katrina: There's only the head left
Alice:有点甜
Alice: It's a bit sweet
Jake:什么线嗯
Jake: What cable, hmm?
Jake:iPhone的线吗
Jake: iPhone cable?
Alice:不知道加了多少糖
Alice: No idea how much sugar was added
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake:iPhone的线
Jake: iPhone cable
Alice:嗯致死量的糖
Alice: Hmm, lethal amount of sugar
Alice:快晕过去了
Alice: I'm about to faint
Alice:啊被你甜晕了
Alice: Ah, you've sweetened me to fainting
Alice:哈哈哈你的甜蜜攻击
Alice: Haha, your sweet attack
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Tasha: 好好好
Tasha: Okay, okay
Alice:俘获我的心
Alice: You've captured my heart
Alice:哈哈好好好
Alice: Haha, okay, okay
Alice:我今天晚上想洗个澡
Alice: I want to take a bath tonight
Tasha: 你要不要去楼上洗
Tasha: Do you want to go upstairs to wash?
Jake:喂他我
Jake: Hey, him, me
Jake:我给你看一下
Jake: Let me show you something.
Jake:那是不是你
Jake: Is this you?
Alice:开了灯有有声音的话应该也没人进
Alice: If the lights are on and there's noise, no one should come in.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Katrina: 你们一般几点睡
Katrina: What time do you guys usually go to bed?
Alice:我昨天3点多睡的
Alice: I went to bed around 3 AM yesterday.
Tasha: 他每天只需要睡4个小时
Tasha: He only needs 4 hours of sleep a day.
Alice:no那是以前
Alice: No, that was before.
Jake:应该是你的摸错了是吧
Jake: You must have touched it wrong, right?
Katrina: 不是我是那个苹果壳
Katrina: No, it was the Apple case.
Jake:哎
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 哎哎哎苹果壳在这我试试
Katrina: Ah, ah, ah, the Apple case is here, let me try it.
Jake:明天还要买什么呀
Jake: What do we need to buy tomorrow?
Katrina: 不用买呀
Katrina: No need to buy anything.
Jake:薄荷叶
Jake: Mint leaves.
Alice:鸡蛋需要补充一下呀
Alice: We need to restock on eggs.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:鸡蛋
Jake: Eggs.
Katrina: 停止外送旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Stop delivering Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 这两个34G的下单
Katrina: These two 34G ones, place the order.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 时钟你买是吧
Katrina: You're buying the clock, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 这个我买了
Katrina: I already bought this.
Alice:这个蛋糕坯烤得还挺好吃的就是奶油有点
Alice: The cake base tastes pretty good, but the cream is a bit...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 234 他买就行
Katrina: 234, he can just buy it.
Alice:今晚上是不是又要看那个装修
Alice: Are we watching that renovation show again tonight?
Alice:装 不 装饰
Alice: Decor... no, decoration.
Katrina: 还要看一下跳什么舞
Katrina: We also need to see what dance to perform.
Jake:嗯对跳跳舞
Jake: Yeah, let's dance.
Alice:装饰的
Alice: The decoration one.
Jake:装饰的装饰一下
Jake: The decoration one, let's decorate.
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decoration.
Alice:我想跟你睡一起了
Alice: I want to sleep with you.
Alice:我可以抄你的装饰
Alice: Can I copy your decoration?
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decoration.
Jake:装修的话
Jake: If it's about renovation...
Lucia: 我刚才也在想
Lucia: I was just thinking...
Lucia: 有没有哪位同学把自己的房间装修
Lucia: Did any of you decorate your room?
Lucia: 给我抄一抄
Lucia: Can I copy it?
Jake:哈哈对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:装修可能讨论讨论
Jake: Maybe we can discuss the decoration.
Katrina: 小红书照着买吧
Katrina: Just follow the ideas from Xiaohongshu.
Jake:就是多开个PPT开个投影
Jake: Just open a PPT and a projector.
Jake:聊聊天看看图之类的
Jake: Chat, look at pictures, and stuff.
Alice:啊怎么
Alice: Ah, how about...
Alice:啊看看组
Alice: Ah, let's look at...
Jake:是看看图看看图
Jake: Yes, look at pictures, look at pictures.
Jake:刷刷网页
Jake: Browse websites.
Alice:是自己的房间吗
Alice: Is it our own rooms?
Jake:对啊互相扯扯
Jake: Yeah, just chat with each other.
Jake:就是就互相扯扯
Jake: Just chat with each other.
Lucia: 我们做完设计以后还要做一个PPT
Lucia: Do we have to make a PPT after the design?
Lucia: 向大家汇报一下吗
Lucia: To present to everyone?
Jake:呃PPT不用做
Jake: Uh, no need for a PPT.
Jake:就看网页就好了
Jake: Just browse websites.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Katrina: 看网页
Katrina: Browse websites.
Katrina: 直接用这个
Katrina: Just use this.
Katrina: 看手机不就行了
Katrina: Isn't it fine to just use phones?
Jake:哦也对
Jake: Oh, that's right.
Jake:就是手机互相传阅是吧
Jake: Just share the phones around, right?
Katrina: 为什么要看别人的
Katrina: Why look at others'?
Jake:你自己看是吧
Jake: You look at your own, right?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Jake:哦你们要偷偷的自己搞
Jake: Oh, you want to secretly do it yourself.
Jake:不跟别人分享
Jake: Not share with others.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:你原来是
Jake: You used to...
Alice:那我的原来花里胡哨乱搞风
Alice: My room used to be a mess.
Jake:应该是
Jake: Should be...
Katrina: 倒也不是
Katrina: Not really.
Katrina: 我也是我要搞五颜六色
Katrina: I also want to make it colorful.
Lucia: 可是墙上不能贴的话
Lucia: But if we can't stick things on the wall...
Lucia: 我在想我应该怎么弄
Lucia: I'm thinking about what to do.
Katrina: 美文纸明天叫个外送看看
Katrina: Try ordering decorative paper online.
Katrina: 如果他要是真的效果挺好的话就可以
Katrina: If it looks good, then we can use it.
Jake:你们都吃完了
Jake: Have you all finished eating?
Jake:就剩我一个了
Jake: I'm the only one left.
Katrina: 韩胜萍没吃
Katrina: Han Shengping didn't eat.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: 还有一个
Katrina: There's one more.
Katrina: 我等会我等会
Katrina: Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Katrina: 工作一会我又饿了
Katrina: I worked for a bit and got hungry again.
Jake:对工作工作
Jake: Yeah, work, work.
Katrina: 就是现在还没有消化
Katrina: I just haven't digested yet.
Katrina: 我是那种吃的很少
Katrina: I eat very little.
Katrina: 但是我就是呃
Katrina: But I...
Katrina: 吃的少但是也饱的快
Katrina: I get full quickly.
Katrina: 饱的快小鸟胃马上又又饿了
Katrina: I get full quickly, like a bird's stomach, and then I'm hungry again.
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Bird's stomach.
Katrina: 饿的也快
Katrina: I get hungry quickly too.
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Bird's stomach.
Lucia: 好难想啊
Lucia: It's so hard to think.
Alice:好折磨我呀
Alice: It's torturing me.
Lucia: 为什么我们突然播出了这个环节呢
Lucia: Why did we suddenly broadcast this segment?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:我看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake:我们用完之后
Jake: After we finish using it...
Alice:用完之后没
Alice: After using it, isn't there...
Jake:我们的计划
Jake: Our plan...
Alice:接东西
Alice: Something to connect.
Jake:我们给你们的保底计划
Jake: Our bottom line plan for you.
Jake:我们原来是说我们会出一个方案
Jake: Originally, we said we would come up with a plan.
Jake:然后如果你们这个方案能你
Jake: And if you guys could...
Jake:你们能整个挪活的话
Jake: If you could move the whole thing.
Jake:那就用你们的方案
Jake: Then we'll use your plan.
Jake:就是我们尽量的整活
Jake: We'll try to make it work.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊 出去玩去吧
Katrina: Ah, let's go out and play.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:那这些东西
Alice: And these things...
Alice:扔哪去什么这些
Alice: Where should we throw these?
Katrina: 什么
Katrina: What?
Alice:就是用完之后的
Alice: The things after using them.
Alice:没用完的
Alice: The unused ones.
Lucia: 好饱啊哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm so full, hahaha.
Katrina: 你好呀
Katrina: Hi there.
Lucia: 哈哈突然出现啊
Lucia: Haha, you suddenly appeared!
Alice:被你吓了一跳
Alice: You scared me!
Katrina: 挑一挑
Katrina: Let's pick one.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 因为懒得把这挪走
Lucia: I was too lazy to move it.
Lucia: 就直接坐在这个小马上了
Lucia: So I just sat on this small horse.
Alice:是不是该刷碗了
Alice: Shouldn't we wash the dishes?
Alice:好痛苦啊
Alice: It's so painful.
Alice:杨老师会说真读假读真的
Alice: Mr. Yang will teach us how to read correctly.
Alice:我们外卖还没扔呢
Alice: We haven't thrown away the takeout yet.
Lucia: 哦对我们剩的外卖还没有收拾
Lucia: Oh right, we haven't cleaned up the leftover takeout.
Alice:上边的
Alice: The stuff on top.
Alice:还没收拾
Alice: We haven't cleaned it up.
Alice: ：然后就收拾住了
Alice: Then let's clean it up.
Jake:啊什么东西
Jake: Huh, what is this?
Lucia: 是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Right, haha.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
爱丽是吗
Alice: Right?
Jake:啥
Jake: What?
Katrina: 啥
Katrina: What?
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right.
Jake:是啊什么东西
Jake: Yeah, what is it?
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What is it?
Jake:是啥呀
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈打哑谜
Lucia: Haha, playing charades.
Tasha: 他说你会把这东西都洗掉
Tasha: He said you would clean all this up.
Jake:呵
Jake: Oh.
Jake:哦哦哦哈哈好行呵呵
Jake: Oh oh oh haha, okay, haha.
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Jake:我们给你们
Jake: We have some proposals for you.
Jake:我们有一些proposal
Jake: We have some proposals.
Jake:一个是
Jake: One is...
Lucia: 说来听听
Lucia: Let's hear it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:嗯也不是
Jake: Well, it's not really...
Jake:就是这中间几天怎么整活了
Jake: Just how to handle things these days.
Jake:一些proposal
Jake: Some proposals.
Alice:哎眼镜呢
Alice: Hey, where are my glasses?
Jake:额
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 给我们一些灵感嘛
Lucia: Give us some inspiration.
Lucia: 说不定我们听了之后会有更多的ID的
Lucia: Maybe after we listen, we'll have more ideas.
Jake:对好的好的
Jake: Yeah, sure, sure.
Jake:哎你的
Jake: Hey, your...
Jake:你的眼镜好了
Jake: Your glasses are ready.
Katrina: 我的风铃挂在哪里呢
Katrina: Where should I hang my wind chime?
Lucia: 网好差呀
Lucia: The internet is so bad.
Katrina: 刷不出东西
Katrina: Can't load anything.
Jake:哎老三呢
Jake: Hey, where's Number Three?
Alice:上楼了拿东西去
Alice: Went upstairs to get something.
Jake:这是他手机
Jake: This is his phone.
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:你给他带上
Jake: Bring it to him.
Lucia: 咱这有洗衣机吗
Lucia: Do we have a washing machine?
Jake:有就在那边
Jake: Yes, it's over there.
Lucia: 看看这个
Lucia: Look at this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 啊他前面被堵住了
Lucia: Ah, it's blocked in front.
Lucia: 门口应该有个灯
Lucia: There should be a light at the door.
Lucia: 让我研究一下
Lucia: Let me figure it out.
Lucia: 咱们需要洗衣服的数据吗
Lucia: Do we need the laundry data?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:呃可以有
Jake: Uh, we could.
Jake:可以洗
Jake: We can wash.
Lucia: 因为我想把我这个裤子洗一下
Lucia: Because I want to wash these pants.
Lucia: 不过我光手洗一下
Lucia: But I'll just hand wash.
Lucia: 那个沾到沾到奶油的地方
Lucia: The part that got cream on it.
Jake:那也可以用它 对
Jake: You can use it too, right.
Lucia: 或者就是直接撂进去
Lucia: Or just throw it in directly.
Lucia: 他这有洗衣液
Lucia: There's detergent here.
Lucia: 哎还真有
Lucia: Oh, there really is.
Jake:有
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊好全啊
Lucia: Ah, it's all so complete.
Lucia: 嗯啊
Lucia: Mmm-hmm.
Lucia: 我想想
Lucia: Let me think.
Lucia: 那我又要上去一下了
Lucia: I need to go upstairs again.
Lucia: 让我换个裤子就下来
Lucia: Let me change my pants, then I'll come down.
Jake:有一个火锅抽奖   抽食材
Jake: There's a hotpot lottery, drawing ingredients.
Lucia: 抽食材
Lucia: Draw the ingredients
Jake:抽抽到什么吃什么
Jake: Draw and eat whatever you get
Lucia: 听着好像呃
Lucia: Sounds like, uh
Jake:哈哈就是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's exactly what it means
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔噔米噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun dun rice dun dun
Tasha: 就是
Tasha: Exactly
Alice:你的眼镜好了
Alice: Your glasses are fixed
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes
Alice:me
Alice: me
Jake:you
Jake: you
Katrina: 这也是要自己做啊
Katrina: Do I have to do this myself too?
Lucia: 来观摩一下
Lucia: Let's take a look
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 来观摩一下你打算怎么改造你的房间
Lucia: Let's see how you're planning to renovate your room
Tasha: 首先先把屏量放这
Tasha: First, put the screen over here
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my
Katrina: 设计专业的
Katrina: Design major
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈procreate专业
Lucia: Haha, procreate major
Jake:完了你设计完估计还要做president大家
Jake: After you design it, you'll probably have to present it to everyone
Alice:什么president
Alice: What presentation?
Katrina: 别吓唬他
Katrina: Don't scare him
Jake:就是要
Jake: I mean
Jake:呃秀硕给你讲一遍
Jake: Uh, Shure will explain it to you
Jake:就是秀硕把你的房间帮你讲一遍
Jake: Shure will help you explain your room
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:没有没有没有乱说
Jake: No, no, just kidding
Lucia: 我们还有这个环节
Lucia: We have this segment too?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no
Jake:就是我是说
Jake: I mean
Jake:他可能最后能做出个视频出来
Jake: He might make a video at the end